uncomfortably overrated welcome to
another episode of
underrated overrated with me garyvee
[Music]
first before i go into this episode
thank you so much to everybody that lost
their mind for this show
i think we've got several episodes we're
about to film drock
take it away pork indian wine portuguese
wine
underrated wildly underrated i'm telling
you right now under 20 bucks
maybe the best in the world really
eilish billy eilish
underrated i think if you think about
the next 10 years she's got more in the
can
hollywood wildly overrated i think
hollywood is being disrupted
but the talent there is incredible and
it has been america's ultimate weapon
for
80 years but i'm still gonna go with
overrated at this moment
triller triller properly rated
winning in certain areas but still has a
lot to go you
can't just be an alternative to
government regulation
but i i believe there might be some
innovation there pokemon
pokemon underrated the cards are
underrated the ip is underrated go look
up the value of pokemon's ip
versus star wars twitter please twitter
fleets
overrated i think that it's a okay
feature on twitter i just right at this
second it's only a couple weeks in but
i'm gonna go with slightly overrated
king king batch wildly underrated i'll
do it right here on the show
king batch will be one of the biggest
actors in hollywood
10 years from the filming of this one of
the 10 15
biggest actors in hollywood james
carroll properly rated
has a cult like following humongous
following still not known by a lot of
the mainstream
has had some flub ups and but is going
through it young person
i think properly rated which is pretty
solid day trading
day trading is the most underrated thing
in the world being fast and executing
works it works on wall street it really
works in marketing
wildly underrated maybe the most
underrated thing we've done in the show
day trading attention is my religion
drake
drake this is a good one
i would say drake is underrated i think
drake's underrated because
i think he's wildly rated but i think
people like to hate when someone's at
the top and if you just think about the
output of music and cultural relevance i
also think he has a humility card
that is underrated i think drake is
underrated
injury reserve in sports injury reserve
i would say injury reserve
is i don't even know where to go this
injury reserve is overrated just because
i want something to be overrated
kanye west entrepreneurial career
properly rated i'll tell you why i think
a lot of people grossly underrate him
because he's done a bunch of stuff and i
fully expect his impact on gap to matter
i think some people overrate him because
they've got him on jesus status and
i'd like to see a couple more things out
of him to go there
i think connie is properly rated hype
house hype houses are overrated we're
talking about all of them right
it's fun i like them but i think there's
a lot of
underlining anxiety and mockery
that isn't talked about enough and i
just i don't think a lot of people are
going to leave hype houses like
awesomely better off i'm not hating but
i think they're overrated i think
there's a lot of people 15 years old
right now watching
dying to one day live in a hype house
and i don't think
they need it as much as they think nba
young boy
young boy never broke again i think he
is a
underrated energy if you look under 20
year old fan bases
there might not be a bigger one out
there and so you know he's got a lot
going on i'd love to chop it up with
that kid one day
pirate thing parrot bay the place in
turks and caicos no like where you
ripped where you rip off like the
software and all that
oh pirate bay pirate bay is
grossly underrated i think pirating and
you know i have so many of my books
ripped off there like i think it's an
important part of society i think it's a
ying to the yang that is mainstream
society
and i will go with pirate bay being
underrated verification
uncomfortably overrated being verified
has become this crazy status symbol
that people clout on and most people use
it as
a douchebag energy and i hate it like
that blue check that verification giving
people clout
is not good it's high school it's bad
i'm not a fan i'm gonna go with vsco
being overrated
believe it or not i think it's wildly
important to a certain demo i think it's
a good app
but it's been the same thing for four
years now which is like another place
for young females to play it out
and i think they haven't innovated
enough i think visco four years ago had
the chance with seven smart moves
innovation m a to be a major player
maybe even
the number one social network so i would
go with visco being
overrated linkedin is wildly underrated
i've been boring for 24 months pounding
the [ __ ] out of all of you
to produce content on it underpriced
attention day trading attention
you can post anything on there teeny bop
influencers can build audience on
linkedin
pumpkin pie pumpkin pie is
[Music]
something i don't like as much as i used
to but i'm gonna go with
overrated because i think pumpkin spiced
lattes have
probably grown pumpkin pie's status and
pumpkin pie is delish
i'm about that pumpkin pie but i'm still
gonna go slightly overrated
sweet potatoes are also slightly
overrated because i think sweet potato
fries have become a huge
game and i think yeah i'm gonna go with
slightly overrated
dog you guys are [ __ ] faces
god damn it i promised myself to always
give my real answer i think dogs are
overrated
i love i don't love dogs are great and i
think that people
love animals more than humans at scale
in a way they think is not right and
it's only because
animals don't communicate the same way
that humans do
and most people are insecure and they
use it like they use animals as an
excuse
for not doing good behavior to other
humans i think dogs are overrated and i
know i'm gonna get blasted doesn't mean
they're bad
i think they're overrated
you guys literally just gave me 48 hours
of like headaches
all right hashtag underrated following
hashtags understanding why hashtags work
is one of the great post creative
strategists if you don't understand at
google it's one of the
great things to understand in society it
is a currency of understanding the
current pulse
of thinking big fan of hashtags grossly
underestimated
black friday sales black friday sales
are now overrated they're
lame they're not innovating they're
boring you're almost getting those same
deals all the time
christmas christmas is properly rated
playstation 5.
playstation 5 is properly rated
card yu-gi-oh cards are underrated they
still have 20 to 100
value uptick in the youngest crew
underneath the pokemon crew those late
20s characters are gonna make yu-gi-oh
cards really pop in a decade
in 15 years a lot of 27 year olds are
gonna have a lot more money and yu-gi-oh
cards are gonna be wildly underpriced
today compared to
what they will be in 15 years josiah the
rapper oh
nice uh decide the rapper wildly
underrated thank you
facebook is underrated people [ __ ] on
facebook at scale today
it is still one of the most significant
platforms it dominates 50 to 100 year
olds attention
the platform has over indexed in its
ability to change facebook marketplace
groups
facebook is underrated i also predict
that facebook in 40 years will have a
reboot
nostalgic brand change there will be
some form of like the newest
social network after being kind of
dormant for a while
underrated the final one taco bell taco
bell
is overrated i think it's an incredible
brand i'm a big fan i love their
marketing but if i'm being honest i'm
shooting and that's what i'm doing here
it's
it's feeling a little stale i think it
needs to do some action
that was overrated underrated with
garyvee please tune in to the next
episode
[Music]